i'm a mathematician there are counting
numbers and we always start counting at
0.
so 0
1
2. in school you do this and you have
rationals and reals and things but we'll
just put the integers for now these are
the things that we learn in school to
add and multiply we notice that there's
not a biggest one if i ask you can you
find a bigger integer than 100
101 101 excellent
how about a million
million and one
pretty good
so for any n in the natural numbers this
is this blackboard bowl face that's its
name in for n and n
there is let's call it k
bigger than n
agreed you just added 1 to the numbers i
gave you you can always do that but what
about if we want a really big k
so what about a k
bigger than n for all n and so there's
not anything in this list here of
natural numbers or our imagined list
that goes on forever there's nothing
there that's bigger than all the others
because you can always add one but i'm a
model theorist we don't just look at n
we look at other number systems
and there's one in which we have
a k that's bigger
than all of these
out here let's put in
i'll call it n star i'll just say it's
another version of n
it has a lot of the same properties of n
but we can give ourselves
a number out here
which is bigger than all of these at
once so we're greedy or we're lazy or we
say why not
because we're mathematicians of course
it's not bigger than itself it's not
bigger than k plus one
but for the ordinary natural numbers
it's bigger but it's still a natural
number it's still a natural number and
so it has
lots of the properties of natural
numbers now
we can do this because we're model
theorists and we use something called
the compactness theorem
but there's a cost we have to be careful
what we can say and what we can't say
but we can say about these infinite
integers and they're more i'll get to
that in a second we can say about these
infinite integers whether they're even
or odd whether they're prime whether
they're squares all of those are
properties of ordinary natural numbers
and so you can ask that about your
new and wonderful infinite one so hang
on
is this infinity
they're all infinite they they're bigger
than all of the finite numbers but
what you know when people say the
infinity that's not what we're talking
about there are lots of kinds of
infinity that the set theorists talk
about but even here we're talking about
just a nice
listable countable thing with a lot of
elements in it that are bigger than all
the natural numbers and
if this were even for example
what does it mean to be even
you say an integer is even if it's equal
to twice another one
yeah yeah well then what about l
l is infinite too
it sits here somewhere
it's less than k because k is double
it but it's out here it's bigger than
all of these
if i start with k and start counting
backwards where am i going to end up you
do it forever okay k minus 1 k minus 2 k
minus a million all infinite and i'll
never get back to that line that's got n
on it no
never any more than you ever end here as
you go up one
going up one never takes you a step at a
time outside n
so there's something else going on that
allows us to have k actually i'm going
to draw the number line now or the the
real numbers let's say or the rationals
it doesn't matter
so let's think about all the numbers
like pi pi should be somewhere about
here right
square root of 2 goes in here
so in school we learn this line
and in all the real numbers this have an
ordering too right we have positive
elements on the right negative on the
left these have square roots these don't
but we can think about the ordering and
say okay i want something which is
bigger than all the integers just
mention the integers again
and here we go with k
it's out here
we can play the same game starting with
the real numbers
and get an infinite real number and of
course it's got all its buddies it's got
a whole copy of this as buddies and more
because what about now before we divided
by 2 if k was even
but in the real numbers all the non-zero
elements and k is certainly not zero all
the non-zero elements you can take the
reciprocals you can divide by them
so what happens with 1 over k
so this is what this is almost like 1
divided by infinity almost it almost is
and so 1 over k where does it fit in
this line well it's not out here
actually minus k is out here
you could think of that it's beyond all
the negatives the regular ones these are
the ordinary reals
k is here
1 over
k is positive
and it fits
infinitesimally close to zero positive
so one over k is smaller than one over
three one over four one over five one
over n and so forth it's just getting
tighter and tighter into that zero it's
an infinitesimal which is something 19th
century mathematicians and some current
physicists like to have
uh it's infinitesimal and so around
every around zero we have what i think
some of the philosophers called a monad
which is a whole little interval
of elements which are infinitely close
that's the monad if you will
so they're all things like 1 over k or
in our earlier line 1 over
1 over a half k 1 over 2 k 1 over k all
of those they're all there they're all
in there if they're all infinitely close
yeah
are they occupying the same space no
no there's room
there's room
we just put them all in there and
they're in an order like one over k
is going to be bigger than one over k
squared for example
so 1 over x so the ordering out here is
just flipped when you put it here so 1
over k squared is closer to the 0 than 1
over k although they're both infinitely
small yes
one of the things that's fun to do
either within or the reals
is a sort of thought of experiment
thinking
well okay are there infinite primes
are there infinite integers that are the
products of exactly two primes
uh
are there infinite integers that are
powers of two